if you're trying to figure out how to
back up your iPhone to iCloud here's how
go to your settings app and tap on your
name and tap iCloud make sure your
photos iCloud syncing is enabled as well
as anything else you want backed up and
then tap on iCloud backup and enable it
your iPhone will now automatically back
up whenever it's connected to power
locks and connected to Wi-Fi or cellular
on 5G models if you enable that feature
you can also tap the backup Now button
at any time to do it manually now if you
get an error message saying there's not
enough iCloud storage that's likely
because Apple's free 5 gigabyte plan
isn't enough so within the iCloud page
tap manage account storage and then tap
change storage plan where you can
upgrade to more now if that wasn't the
problem you likely have more data on
your iPhone than your iCloud storage
plan so to fix that within the manage
account storage page you'll see which
apps are using the most storage if
backups is one of those tap on it and
delete any old backups from devices you
know no longer have or care about and if
a huge amount of space is being used by
the photos app open it and go to the
album's view go down to Media types and
tap on videos proceed to select and
delete the videos you don't really care
to keep since videos take up much more
storage than photos do once you delete
them go back to the album view go down
to the recently deleted page and then
tap the select button and tap delete all
to erase them from your storage and if
that's not enough go to your settings
app General and tap iPhone storage here
you can see and delete large apps using
up your storage and preventing iCloud
backups thanks for watching And
subscribe for more helpful videos like
this one